commencer notre émission avec les
retraites
les discussions ont encore lieu à
l'heure qu'il est à matignon se sont pas
d'ailleurs une négo c'est pas une
négociation général puisque le premier
ministre reçoit les syndicats
l'un après l'autre on se demande
pourquoi puisque le même gouvernement a
rendu public le projet de loi sur la
réforme des retraites et celui ci
prévoit notamment ce fameux âge pivot
qui révulse ce temps les syndicats dits
réformistes
alors est-ce que c'est figé ou est-ce
que c'est pas figé ben apparemment les
choses peuvent encore évoluer écouter
stanislas guérini c'est le patron de la
république en marche et pour lui le
message est clair nous on est très
gentil et on veut négocier je crois que
c'est tout sauf du passage en force
et depuis le début des négociations
depuis début des discussions
on a montré gouvernement a montré qu'ils
étaient capables de bouger qu'ils
étaient capables de faire beaucoup de
propositions
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est que
du côté des syndicats aussi on a des
idées de proposition ce qui semblerait
donc accréditer l'idée que l' affaire
n'est pas terminée ce matin le patron de
l'unsa qui est l'un des deux grands
syndicats réformistes avec la cfdt était
l'invité de rtl est alors lui il a des
idées pour contourner la pivot parce que
s'il ya un aspect bosser parce qu'il
faut trouver de l'argent mais pour lui
on peut trouver d'autres moyens par
exemple taper dans les réserves
regardez vous proposons ce cocktail de
mesures dans lequel chacun doit faire un
effort nous pouvons aussi parlé des
réserves du fonds de réserve qui avait
été mis en place par lionel jospin pour
les retraites justement il fait 20
milliards donc il faut qu'on se dise
quand on regarde l'ensemble de ces
critères de ses moyens financiers de
dire que chacun doit faire un effort
vous nous dites qu'à des solutions mais
qu'elles sont peut-être pas si compliqué
que ça quand je vous écoute tout à fait
et c'est donc une volonté politique et
c'est pour ça que nous pensons qu'il y à
une sortie possible autour de cette
question d'âge pivot et d' équilibre
l'équilibré est important mais ce ne
sont pas toujours les salariés qui
doivent faire cet effort
alors je vous des cônes la nana phrase
de l'ucpf arrêts ce ne sont pas toujours
les salariés qui doit faire cet effort
ça veut dire nous allons demander au
patronat d'augmenter
les cotisations retraites pour financer
le régime
étienne girard c'est quoi ça c'est un
jeu de dupes à ce que le gouvernement
s'apprête à céder sur ce point de l'âge
pivot non ça s'appelle jouer sur tous
les tableaux
le gouvernement veut aller vite pour
éviter que la situation s'enlise
davantage donc faire passer son projet
de loi le plus rapidement possible ce
qui sera pas aussi rapide que ça
puisqu'il y aura une pause pendant les 2
du parlement pendant les élections
municipales
mais ça veut dire en première lecture au
parlement
éventuellement en février ça veut dire
un vote après vers le mois d'avril
c'est le plus rapidement le plus rapide
possible pour le gouvernement pourquoi
il ya toujours en même temps des
discussions avec les syndicats
c'est que le gouvernement veut aussi se
ménager des plans b le plan a c'est on
ne modifie absolument pas le projet et
si la situation politique fait qu' il
devient absolument nécessaire de lâcher
on garde le lien avec les syndicats
qu'on appelle les syndicats réformistes
que le gouvernement qualifie d'
interlocuteur donc la cfdt et l'unsa en
priorité la soupape de sécurité c'est
évidemment là ce pivot
le gouvernement aimerait ne pas lâcher
sur l'âge pivot parce que c'est un
marqueur important de sa réforme
notamment à l'égard de l'électorat de la
droite
si la situation politique l'exigent il
faudra renoncer à cet âge pivot mais
pour l'instant on n'est pas forcément
dans une situation politique où le
gouvernement est acculé au point de
devoir activer son plan b tu veux un
trouble vous partagez cette cette
analyse se décrypte attaquant fait le
gouvernement veut avoir deux fers au feu
sans choisir nécessairement il est vrai
danger c'est que dans sa main il perdre
la droite en se ralliant aux solutions
de l'unsa qui sont aussi celles de
laurent berger grosso modo c'est à dire
taper dans les réserves
et augmenter les cotisations patronales
ce qui a pour conséquence directe de
renchérir le coût du travail qui est
déjà bien supérieures en france à ce
qu'il est dans les pays voisins puis
taper dans les réserves
je rappelle que ça peut être une mesure
transitoire mais quoi qu'on fasse la
démographie restera
une cause des équilibres du système donc
ça n'aura qu'un temps
quand bien même il se passera rien
pendant la période longue date dans la
réserve qui nécessiterait que justement
on les utilise ses réserves
donc en cédant à ce genre de proposition
le gouvernement risque de perdre
effectivement l'électorat de droite qui
est le dernier à le soutenir mais elle
soutenir activement les rites orages et
non concernés par la réforme qui lui
aussi le soutien cédé 2,2 électorat qui
ce qui se croisent sans gagner
l'électorat de gauche parce que pour
l'électorat de gauche s'est toujours pas
de mesures sociales
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est que
devant charlotte on hésite d opinion
assez tranché en tout cas ce qui
s'exprime en direct sur twitter
au fur et à mesure qu'ils écoutent
l'émission l'eau nous dit arrêtons de
poser tout le temps la même question
emmanuel macron n'a pas changé d'opinion
et romain alors qu'ils lui et sur
lefigaro.fr nous dit le gouvernement
pliera mais ne cédera pas voilà puis
deux points de vue aussi de nicole 06
même si le gouvernement donne
l'impression de ne pas céder
le fait de faire des régimes spécifiques
revient à ne pas changer alors ça c'est
effectivement l'autre l'autre front de
cette bataille des retraites il ya d'une
part la spi veau et d'autre part les
régimes spéciaux
alexandre de vécu ou est ce que le
gouvernement spécialement intelligent
au point que personne ou presque n'y
comprennent rien ou à votre avis il
risque de se prendre les pieds dans le
tapis
non mais il ya la forme la forme je
partage qui a été dit je pense que le
gouvernement ne cédera pas effectivement
je dirais pas que c'est l'électorat de
droite mais la droite libérale et les
retraités particulièrement soutiennent
le gouvernement est donc il veut garder
cet électorat là effectivement s'il
retire l âge pivot il perdrait ses
soutiens la sent même arrêter les
blocages puisque je ne suis pas sûr que
la cfdt soit capable d'arrêter les
blocages sa base et pas forcément en
accord avec laurent berger surtout la
cgt continuerait à bloquer donc
effectivement sa stratégie est sans
doute la bonne pour avoir une victoire
qui est symbolique purement symbolique
parce qu'effectivement il n'y a pas
grand chose dans cette réforme des
retraites jeudi symbolique parce que je
pense que toute manière le gouvernement
va être animée effectivement il tient
avec cette petite minorité mais il ya le
jeu parce que le pays a mis un grand
malaise par rapport au gouvernement donc
c'est tenir avec 25% et c'est je pense
pas que c'est comme ça qu'on relance
réellement le le pays ensuite si on veut
aller sur le fond de la réforme où il
n'y a pas grand chose puisque
l'universalité on a bien vu était un
prétexte pour imposer la réforme pas
points mais il n'y a pas de réelle dit
y'a pas de l'universalité les
professions qui sont susceptibles de
bloquer ont toujours leurs régimes
spéciaux les cheminots en premier lieu
85% sont pas concernés par la réforme ça
ne touchera que ceux qui sont nés après
1975 donc on voit bien que ce soit au
point point de vue là le compte n'y est
pas en réalité pour cette réforme on
pouvait jouer sur différents paramètres
augmenter les cotisations augmenter le
départ de l'âge à la retraite ou baissé
l'épanchement je crois que là c'est un
peu la triple peine puisque les pros
professions libérales sans doute vont
voir leurs copies de cotisation flamber
on a gardé l'âge pivot ce qui est
peut-être la mesure la plus simple à
comprendre peut-être qu'effectivement
pour la question de la démocratie il
faut travailler un peu plus longtemps et
sans doute les pensions vont baisser
parce que moi je crois depuis le début
que le point pourra être modifiée par la
suite c de c dans la loi et que ce sera
une manière d'avoir une retraite en
fonction des contraintes budgétaires je
regrette que les enjeux de fond encore
une fois n'est pas été soulevée qui
effectivement la question de la
démographie il faudra peut-être faire
des enfants de ce pays et ensuite la
question du travail laquelle une
politique qui a un site ces dernières
années ces dernières années par les
enfants forcément c'est derrière
attends si ces dernières années la
politique familiale la politique
familiale n'encourage pas vrai
n'encourage pas les gens à faire des
enfants et ensuite le travail qui est
quand même un problème dans ce pays
frère une réelle politique de croissance
donc donc on n'y est pas donc c'est une
réforme qui n'a pas de sens si ce n'est
d'avoir une victoire symbolique
effectivement pour les retraités qui ont
besoin d'être d'être assurés qu'ils
veulent finir leur vie soit sans grand
chambardement mais je ne crois pas que
l'on gouverne un pays pour l'avenir en
se focalisant uniquement sur les
retraites
mathis banques et quand vous entendez
les responsables des syndicats dits
réformistes proposé d'augmenter plutôt
les cotisations ou de se servir des
réserves ça vous inquiète tout ça vous
paraît un compromis raisonnable
moi je pense que sur le sujet de la
réforme des retraites de manière
générale je pense que le gouvernement a
fait une énorme erreur c'est de vouloir
attaquer et l'équilibré budgétaire et la
réforme systémique c'est à dire que ils
ont négocié pendant deux ans et puis on
se retrouve avec un blocage énorme du
pays donc maintenant ils veulent aller
très vite
d'abord il aurait dû le faire un beau
coup plus tôt ça très fort et 2
peut-être qu attaquer les deux points
ensemble c'était pas une bonne idée moi
je pense que la réforme systémique
elle est réelle on parlait de
démographie on n'arrête pas alors moi
j'ai pas le même point de vue que vous
sur le fait qu'il faudrait même plutôt
inciter à faire des enfants
je pense qu'au contraire il faudrait
qu'on laisse les gens faire bien ce
qu'ils veulent en tout cas pour la
question de faire des emprunts on va les
forcer la démographie voilà un peu plus
de raison non plus de les inciter à
faire des enfants à la politique génial
depuis longtemps on a déjà une blafarde
dans ce pays a pas de raison de
l'augmenter par contre sur la question
de la démographie c'est ce que vous
abordez je pense que il faut que les
gens se rendent compte qu'en france on
reste pays d'europe on retravaille le
moins longtemps
oui il faut qu'on travaille plus
longtemps quoi c'est vrai et et le
système à points va aussi permettre de
prendre en considération les carrières
hachées
les changements de carrière en cours de
vie etc etc
ce qui est finalement probablement de
l'avenir du travail dans ce pays donc
c'est ça correspond plus
en tout cas au niveau systémique et je
pense qu'au bout d'un moment ils
lâcheront cette histoire de d'âge pivot
mais plus tard plutôt comme la carotte
qui va permettre de finir d'éteindre
la contestation pour pouvoir faire
passer la réforme partant d'accord avec
ce point de vue moi je pense qu'ils
peuvent eux ils peuvent enfin gagné
symbolique parce que avec 25 % au
maximum de gens réellement content c'est
une victoire très molle mais je pense
que les syndicats jouaient leur dernière
carte c'est en fait c'est deux mondes
qu'ils sont en train de mourir un monde
technocratique et comptables qui n'a pas
de solution pour la france et qui va
imposer sa réforme au forceps mais qui
aura bien de la peine à gouverner par la
suite et les mondes le monde de des
syndicats qui sont finalement très peu
représentatif qui n'ont pas su entraîner
le pays alors qu'il y avait un fort
mécontentement qui dépassait les
catégories traditionnelles représenté
par les syndicats mais on voit bien qu'à
part les cheminots la fonction publique
ils n'ont pas entraîné réellement
derrière eux donc ils ont joué leur
dernière carte avec une position
maximaliste et si la perdre
ils disparaîtront et on va dans le futur
vers un affrontement entre les élites et
de nouveau parti populaire je crois que
c'est là la politique de demain et que
et que là on a un théâtre du vieux monde
le dernier la dernière pièce du vieux
monde qui sait qui est en train de se
jouer
et quand vous dites que c'est peut-être
la fin d'un monde il ya une information
qui vient de tomber que je partage avec
vous et qui est passionnante
la sncf annonce une amélioration
significative du trafic ce week-end et
un retour progressif à la normale à
partir de lundi
c'est ça vous ça vous surprend et angie
râlant même qui avait une grosse
mobilisation hier et qui en aura une
autre demain où il ya un nouveau
mouvement ça me surprend pas puisque la
tendance depuis quelques jours était à
la baisse significative du nombre de
grévistes que les chiffres de
manifestations hier ont été relativement
décevant quand on se réfère par exemple
à la aux manifestations sur la réforme
des retraites sous sarkozy
en 2010 on était à plusieurs reprises à
plus de trois millions de personnes dans
les rues et de plus en plus nombreux
voilà
très bien que sur ce projet là on n'est
pas du tout dans les temps les même
étiage donc pour l'instant on n'est pas
sur une mobilisation qui est massive et
qui acculent le gouvernement au retrait
ou à la modification substantielle du
projet cela dit le sujet derrière tout
ça le sujet politique qui est
passionnant c'est 2022 c'est à dire que
oui macron aujourd'hui en termes de
possibilités politiques
il peut faire passer son projet de loi
parce qu'il a une majorité absolue
confortable à l'assemblée nationale n'y
a pas dans la rue suffisamment de monde
pour que ça empêche le gouvernement de
faire voter le texte
le texte peut passer mais alors comment
on fait pour être élu quand on a fait
passer ce texte là sans le modifier ou
alors en le modifiant à la marge pour
être réélu en 2022 parce que emmanuel
macron il a été élu sur une base 2
centre gauche avoir une base de
sympathisants socialistes sympathisants
hollande east et ces gens là c'est pas
évident qu'ils soient pas opposé au
projet de retraite les mêmes sûr qu'ils
sont majoritairement opposés à
l'orientation choisie et c'est pas du
tout évident qu'ils revoient tron qui ré
achèteront du maquereau en 2022 voilà on
n'a pas encore mesuré sûrement toutes
les conséquences politiques de ce
conflit même si on peut penser que on va
peut-être vers une vers un d